entre les Français et les chats c'est
une belle et longue histoire d'amour on
en compte pas loin de 8 millions c'est
sans doute ça être fait l'un pour
l'autre ce sont des êtres humains à part
entière les chats sont des êtres humains
à partentièr moi je considère comme ça
je dis que Dieu a créé l'homme et il a
trouvé que l'homme n'était pas parfait
alors du coup il a inventé non il a pas
inventé il a créé le chat et il a trouvé
que le chat était tellement parfait
qu'il a fait l'homme l'esclave du chat
et je suis heureuse d'être esclave du
chat pour est-ce que ça dore tout ce
monde là tous dans mon lit tous avec moi
al voyez ils sont combien dans le lit
bah ça dépend j'en ai eu jusqu'à 15 il y
a la place pour le mari ou pas non il a
plus de place va dormir ailleur n'a pas
de prix c'est le représentant en France
de la race je dirais entre entre 15 et
25000 ça c'est une petite ch qui vaut
entre qui vaut entre 8 et 10000 francs
c'est moins cher que l'extraterrestre de
rosewev ouais pe un peu plus authentique
moins de plastique estce que vous
regardez là là n regardez que c'est
important ah oui pu elle est courne
c'est